John has talked about how you should associate hashing with integrity.
John has talked about how you should associate hashing with integrity. So let's play
that out. Let's use a scenario here where I want to send an email to my future
business partner here at Nigel. So I want to send Nigel an email with a contract in place
because he and I are going to start a business together, horse trading. So I want to send an
email containing a legal contract and I want to make sure that Nigel receives exactly
the same contract as what I have sent because it's a business contract. I want to make
sure that the message has integrity. So I create my message here, my email. I write
the email and then I hash the email and I attach that hash value to the email. So now
this email here contains the message of the email and a hash value at the bottom. And
now I send the message over to Nigel here. He receives the message. Now he wants to make
sure that the message, the message that he received has integrity. So how is he going
to do that? Well, he will hash the message that he received and he will compare that
to the hash value that he's just calculated to the one that I attached to the email. And
if those hash values match, then he'll know the message has integrity. So this looks
good, right? We've used hashing to prove the integrity of a message. But there's actually
a big problem here. And to explain this problem, we need to introduce another actor into our
little scenario here. Here's the additional character that we need in our little scenario
here, my malicious munchkin. Here's what's going to happen. We're going to replay the scenario
over again. I'm going to create an email containing some information that I want to have integrity.
That I want Nigel here to know has integrity. So I'm going to write the message. I'm going
to attach the hash value to the message. And I'm going to send that message to Nigel.
My malicious munchkin here is going to perform a malicious munchkin in the middle attack,
a man in the middle attack. She's going to catch the ball. She's going to intercept the message.
Now, she's going to modify the message because does integrity provide, if we've just hashed
the message, does that provide confidentiality? No, she can read the message. And what she can do
is she can modify the message. And then she can just remove my hash value, calculate a new hash
value and send it to Nigel. So that's exactly what she's going to do. She's going to modify the message.
And then she's going to forward it onto Nigel. Nigel is going to receive the message.
He's going to hash the message that he received. He's going to compare that to the hash value that's
attached to the message. And what is he going to find? He's going to find that they match. And so
Nigel is going to assume that the message has integrity. And this is the really big flaw here.
This is why you cannot use simply a hash value attached to a message to prove integrity.
Because any little malicious munchkin here could have intercepted the message in transit.
Change the message, take it off my hash value and replace it with her own or their own and
forward on the message. And the receiver has no idea this has happened.
So this is why we do not simply use a hash value to prove that a message has integrity.
Instead we use digital signatures. So this is what the section is about. We're going to talk about
what we can use digital signatures for and how we create them. So let's start with what can we
use digital signatures for? They provide three services, integrity, authenticity, and non-repediation.
So using digital signatures we can achieve integrity, authenticity, and non-repediation.
Let's start by describing how we create a digital signature. It's actually remarkably easy.
There's only two steps involved. Step one in creating a digital signature is the sender
hashes the message. When you hash a message it produces a fixed length message digest.
So that's step one, hash the message. Step two, and listen very carefully here.
Step two, the sender encrypts the hash value with the sender's private key.
And that produces a digital signature. That's all a digital signature is.
It's simply the hash value of the message, the file, encrypted with the sender's private key.
So how large are digital signatures? They're actually quite small. Because what are we encrypting here?
We're just encrypting a hash value. And how large your hash value is? Well, we've talked about
differing hashing algorithms like MD5 and SHA1 and SHA256. They're creating message digest hash
values between 128 bits, 256 bits, maybe 512 bits at the maximum. So all that we're encrypting
here is a few hundred bits of data, a really small amount of data. And the encryption process does
not add much the size. So digital signatures are very, very small. So let's go through a quick
diagram that shows how this actually works when you have a sender and a receiver and they're
using a digital signature to send a message. So here we're going to use an Alice and Bob diagram.
And we're going to start with the message. So here is the message that Alice wants to send to Bob.
Alice wants to have this message to have integrity, authenticity, and non-repediation. To achieve
those three services, Alice is going to create her own digital signature. There are two steps
required to create a digital signature. I'll step one, Alice will hash the message, producing a
fixed-length message digest. Step two, the sender Alice will encrypt the message digest with her
private key, producing a digital signature. So that's the only steps that are required to create
a digital signature. Alice can now attach that digital signature to the message and send it over to
Bob. Now I want to ask you something and I want you to pay very close attention here.
In sending this message with a digital signature attached, did we achieve confidentiality? Can anyone
read this message? Yes, be very, very clear on this. Digital signatures do not provide confidentiality.
Anyone can read the message. All the digital signatures provide are integrity, authenticity,
and non-repediation. So to achieve integrity, authenticity, and non-repediation, Bob has to do
some work with the digital signature. The first thing he has to do is decrypt it because a digital
signature is ciphertext. So Bob is going to decrypt the digital signature with Alice's public key.
And when Bob decrypts the digital signature with Alice's public key, he's going to get back the
hash value that Alice created. And if that digital signature decrypted with Alice's public key,
who's the only person in the world that could have created that digital signature, Alice with her
private key. So if that digital signature decrypts with Alice's public key, what that proves is
authenticity. Bob knows the message came from Alice. Now the next thing Bob needs to do is he wants to
actually see if there's integrity. So what he has to do is he has to hash the message that
he received. And he needs to compare the hash value that he's just calculated to the hash value
that he received in the message from Alice. And if those hash values match, Bob will know that
the message had integrity. And when you have integrity and authenticity, then you have non-repidiation
of origin. Alice cannot deny that she sent the message because Bob knows it came from Alice,
and he knows the message has integrity. So he knows the message came from Alice, and he knows
the message has not been changed. Therefore, Alice cannot deny non-repidiation of origin that she
sent the message. So that's how we use digital signatures. Okay, now that we understand digital
signatures, let's replay the scenario over again. But instead of attaching just a hash value to the
message, instead I'm going to attach a digital signature. So I'm going to write the message,
and then I'm going to create a digital signature, only two steps involved. I'm going to hash the
message, producing a message digest, and then I'm going to encrypt that message digest with my
private key. And I'm going to attach that digital signature to the message. And then what I'm
going to do is I'm going to forward that message and send that message over to Nigel. Now my
malicious munchkin here being the malicious individual that she is is going to continue to be malicious.
She's going to intercept the message. So she's going to intercept the message.
And now, can she read the message? Yes, digital signatures do not provide confidentiality.
So she can read the message. She can even modify the message, but here's the really important
question. Can she change my digital signature? So she wanted to modify the message and then
modify the hash value inside of my digital signature. Can she do that? No. Because in order to be
able to modify a digital signature, she would need my private key. And I never share my private key
with anyone under any circumstances. And so even though my malicious munchkin here can intercept
the message, and she can read the message, and she can modify the message, she cannot modify
my digital signature. So she could modify the message and forward it on to Nigel, but Nigel would
know because he's not able to modify my digital signature. So when he gets the message, he would
hash the message, he would decrypt my digital signature, and he would compare the hash value
in my digital signature to the hash value that he just calculated, and they will be different.
They won't match. And therefore, he will know the message has been modified.
So by using digital signatures for preventing my little malicious munchkin here, our attacker
from modifying the hash value. Now, there's one other scenario you might be thinking about here,
and that is what if my malicious little munchkin here rather than trying to change my digital signature?
What if she just stripped off my digital signature and attached her own digital signature?
So she could modify the message, she could calculate a new hash value, she could then encrypt that
hash value with her private key, creating her own digital signature, and the hash value in her
digital signature is going to match the message. So she could do all of that, and then she could
forward it on to Nigel. But here's the problem with that. As soon as Nigel receives the message,
he's going to try and decrypt the digital signature attached to it with my public key.
And if it's a digital signature that's been created by my little malicious munchkin with her
private key, it is not going to decrypt with my public key. So Nigel, the receiver is going to know
that this is not my digital signature, he's going to know that this message didn't come from me,
he's going to know it doesn't have authenticity. So this is how digital signatures solve the problem
of a man in the middle, a malicious munchkin in the middle, intercepting a message and modifying
the message and just replacing the hash value. And so remember, digital signatures provide integrity,
authenticity, and non-repediation. The final piece that we need to cover here is what can we use
digital signatures for beyond just what we've already talked about with sending a message?
Well, it can actually be used for all sorts of different things. They can be used for code signing,
like we talked about earlier, so that you can know who some code came from, and that that code
hadn't been modified and trans it. You can even use them for signing documents. There's
many countries jurisdictions in the world that actually have laws on the books that allow you to
use digital signatures to sign legal documents. And in fact, a digital signature is a lot more
trustworthy than an actual signature, because a digital like an actual signature is not impossible to
forge, but to forge a digital signature. What would you need? He would need the sender's private key.
And as long as they've done a very good job of protecting that private key,
it's basically impossible to forge a digital signature. So that's digital signatures.